150 meeting
of the security council is going to
order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is
maintenance of peace and security of
ukraine
the agenda is adopted
i have received a letter from the
permanent representative of ukraine to
the united nations
requesting
that his excellency mr vladimir zelinsky
president of ukraine being invited to
participate
via video teleconference to in today's
meeting in accordance with rule 37 of
the council's provisional rules of
procedure
i'll give the floor to the
representative of the russian federation
thank you mr president
our delegation objects
to the virtual participation of the
president of ukraine vladimir zolensky
in today's meeting
we would like to
explain our objection
we are not opposing the participation of
the president of ukraine or his
representative in the meeting i will
repeat once again for protocol and for
those who will try to distort our
position
we do not object against the
participation of the president of
ukraine in this meeting
however this participation must be in
person in other words he must be
physically present in the council
chamber
this isn't a whim in our part these are
the rules that govern the work of the
council
this isn't about politics it is purely a
procedural matter
it is also a matter of respect for the
members of the council and for the
council as a body
indeed when the world was facing the
coronavirus pandemic we collectively
decided that we would continue working
virtually
but all of our meetings via vtc
according to our collective decision
were informal meetings
then after returning to the council
chamber after the peak of the pandemic
we decided that the council would resume
its normal working patterns which meant
a return to the provisional rules of
procedure as well
in other words if we the members of the
security council are sitting here in the
room other member states participating
under rule 37 must be present here as
well
mr zielenski has already spoken to the
council twice via vcc
each time
we expressed our negative view of this
in writing but the western members of
the council explained back then
and assured us in writing
including the presidents that invited
the president of ukraine that this was
an exception that would not create a
precedent
precedent does not create after a first
or second time
but a third time is no longer an
exception we would like to remind those
members of the council who presided or
will preside in the council
that they
and we have already encountered such
cases
we can understand making a few
exceptions when we had just returned to
the chamber after the pandemic when it
was still preventing the heads of
certain states from traveling
however this year our presidency in
february
as well as other presidents
did not allow high-ranking
representatives of member states to
speak under rule 37 via vtc so why
should there be double standards in the
council on this matter why do other
heads of state or ministers of other
countries that are on the agendas on the
council's agenda subjected to
discrimination
this recalls
the situation with international
humanitarian assistance that rushed into
ukraine when people forgot helping
others in other parts of the world or
the double standards on refugees and
migrants in europe when
refugees from ukraine are green lighted
in every european country while refugees
from africa the middle east and other
regions find themselves facing
barriers
we cannot agree to make an exception for
one country and one person the meeting
was announced a week in advance and the
president had the opportunity to travel
to new york we constantly see zelensky
meeting
foreign delegations traveling around the
country and even posing for photo shoots
for glossy magazines
he is also appointed the head of the
ukrainian delegation at the 77th uh
general session of the general assembly
something that is possible only through
personal participation from all of this
we can draw the conclusion that there
are no restrictions to the president's
movements
we also know that the minister of
foreign affairs of ukraine dmitry kuliba
has been actively traveling abroad
moreover today in this room we see
secretary general antonio guterres who
just recently traveled to ukraine and
visited various cities there i repeat
once again
that what we're objecting to here is not
the participation of the head of the uh
ukraine but rather his participation by
vtc specifically and
if we
ask the president to put this matter to
a procedural vote
i thank the statement by the
representative of the russian federator
uh representative
are there other members who wish to take
floor on this matter i'll give the phone
to the representative albania
thank you very much mr president
we listen carefully to the arguments put
forward by the delegation of russia we
disagree with them and let me explain
we have discussed on this issue in the
past and here we are again unfortunately
since the situation on the ground in
ukraine has not changed has not improved
we agree that in the post-dynamic
situation participation victory and the
rule 37 should be an exception
we are faced with such a situation since
a democratically elected leader of a
sovereign country a member of the united
nations cannot leave his country for
reasons beyond his control
and we all know what the reasons are the
letters of the united kingdom albania
and the united states respectively of 11
april 18 july and 19 july have explained
in detail the reasons for granting the
ukrainian president the possibility to
address the security council virtually
allow me to reiterate that the
justification for this exception remains
unchanged from the previous times when
the council agreed that the president
should could address the council via vtc
it was so in april it was so in june and
it is sadly now
ukraine is at war
under foreign invasion
when a full military attack on a country
ukraine
remains ongoing with independence day
this day
with curfews imposed in various cities
because of that threat
the security council cannot reasonably
demand that the president travels to new
york if he wants to participate in a
session
it is therefore legitimate that we fully
and and we fully understand that in such
circumstances the situation in ukraine
requires president zelinski to be there
this is a unique and exceptional
situation at this moment in the world
and therefore for this council as well
we therefore strongly support the
participation of president zielenski via
vtc
and invite other members to vote in
favor i thank you
okay
i thank the representative of albania
for their statement
are there other members who wish to
speak
in view of the comments made by the
council members
and the request by the representative of
the russian federation i propose to put
to the vote
the following proposal
to which
to extend an invitation to his
excellency mr vladimir zelinsky
president of ukraine to participate
via video teleconference in today's
meeting in accordance with rule 37 of
the council's provisional rules
procedure
i shall put the proposal to the vote now
well those in favor of the proposal to
extend an invitation
under rule 37 of the council's
provisional rules of procedure to his
excellency mr vladimir zielenski
president of ukraine to participate via
video conference please raise their hand
please raise your hands
the proposal to invite his excellency mr
vladimir zielenski
president of ukraine to participate in
today's meeting via vtc
has been adopted
mr president we regret that members of
the council have spoken out
against
complying with the rules of the council
we can understand the logic of kiev's
western backers who are prepared to
sacrifice the entire ukrainian people to
cover up kiev's crimes and the work of
the council as well but we're
disappointed by the fact that other
members who when they come to the
council
undertake the obligation to uphold the
rules of the council today have
contributed to the erosion of its very
foundations and practices we call on all
member states of the u.n to take note of
today's situation despite our position
we will hear out mr zelensky because we
also have something to say to him as
well
we hope that he will remain at today's
meeting until it's very conclusion and
we shall see
will be able to come to the 77th session
of the general assembly as the head of
the general of the ukrainian delegation
or not as the representative of albania
has claimed
i thank the uh
statement by the representative of the
russian federation
i now invite president zelinski to
participate in today's meeting via vtc
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules procedure
i invite ms rosemary de carlo under
secretary general for political and
peace building affairs to participate in
this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules procedure
i also invite his excellency mr silvio
gonzalo
da faire
at interim of the european union
delegation to the united nations it is
so decided
the security council will now begin its
consideration of item two on the agenda
i
am honored to
invite the secretary general his
excellency mr antonio guterres
and i give him the floor
mr president
mr president of ukraine excellencies
today marks a sad and tragic milestone
six months since russia's 24th of
february invasion of ukraine
during this devastating periods
thousands of civilians have been killed
and injured including hundreds of
children
and countless others have lost their
family members friends and loved ones
do all they have seen great violations
of international human rights law and
international humanitarian law
committed with little to no
accountability
and millions of ukrainians have lost
their homes and their worldly
possessions
becoming internally displaced or
refugees
with the onset of winter humanitarian
needs continue to rise rapidly with
millions of people in need of assistance
and protection
as these needs skyrocket it is
imperative that humanitarian actors in
ukraine have safe and inner access to
all people require assistance no matter
where they live
mr president
the consequences
of this senseless war are being felt far
beyond ukraine
we are seeing new vulnerabilities
emerging a global environment already
worn on out by conflicts inequality
pandemic induced economic and earth
crisis and climate change
with a disproportionate impact on
developing countries
the acceleration of already high food
fertilizer and full prices has triggered
the global crisis
that could drive millions more into
extreme poverty
magnifying anger and malnutrition while
threatening to raise the global
humanitarian caseload to new highs and
erase arduino development gains
vulnerable communities are grappling
with the largest cost of living crisis
in a generation and high commodity and
transportation costs are having major
repercussions for existing humanitarian
operations
mr president
and the secretary general rosemary
dicarlo will brief the council on the
impact of the armed conflict in ukraine
both inside and outside the country over
the past six months
as i mentioned on monday i wanted to
take this opportunity to provide a brief
update on my recent travel to ukraine
i would like to have been able to do the
same yesterday
based on my experience in discussions
about zaporizia
but unfortunately i was out of new york
with a
dislocation planned that was impossible
to change at such a short notice
my visit was an important opportunity to
follow up on the landmark deal
that was that has brought a measure of
hope
especially to developing countries and
millions of vulnerable people
bearing the brand of the global food
crisis
some of them on the edge of famine
i can report to the council that the
black sea grant initiative signed in
istanbul in july
is progressing well
with dozens of ships sailing in and out
of ukrainian ports loaded so far with
over
000 metric tons of grains and other food
products
these deals would not have been possible
without the constructive approach of
both ukraine and russia and the efforts
of the government of turkey
during my visit to la viv i met with
ukrainian president zielenski and
turkish president erdogan
i thank them for their continued
engagement to support the implementation
of the initiative to ensure the safe
passage of ukrainian food products and
fertilizers to those in need and to the
world at large
i was filled with emotion
visiting the port of odessa and the
joint coordination center in istanbul
on my visit to odessa i went aboard a
bulk carrier called mv cobrasly why
as it was being loaded with about 10 000
metric tons of wheat
it was deeply moving to peer into the
hold of this cargo ship
and seaweed pouring in
even if in a limited way
the storied part of odessa
which had been paralyzed for months
is slowly coming to life
thanks to the initiative
in istanbul
i saw the double fp chartered ship the
mv brave commander
it was proudly flying the un flag with
its cargo this time destinations for the
horn of africa where millions of people
are at risk a famine
i then had the opportunity to walk up
the long and narrow gangway of the ssi
invincible to
having to keep up ukrainian grain in the
port of chernomorsk
the vessel will carry one of the largest
holes of grain leaving ukraine to date
more than 50 000 metric tons
mr president
just a few weeks ago
much of these would have been hard to
imagine
we are seeing a powerful demonstration
of what can be achieved in even the most
devastating contexts when we put people
first
and i stressed you know this and
istanbul
what i saw was the more visible part of
the solution
the other part of this package deal is
the unimpeded access to global markets
of russian food and fertilizers which
are not subject to sanctions
it is critical that all governments and
the private sector cooperate
to effectively bring them to market
together with the task team led by
rebecca greenspan i will continue my
intense contacts for that purpose
in 2022 there is enough food in the
world
the problem
is its uneven distribution
but if we don't stabilize the fertilizer
market in 2022
there simply will not be enough food in
2023
many farmers around the world are
already planning to reduce areas for
cultivation for next season
getting much more food and fertilizers
out of ukraine and russia at reasonable
cost
is vital to further calm commodity
markets and lower prices for consumers
i once again commend the parties for
their engagement in this process and
urge them to continue to build on
this progress
i also renew the call i made in odessa
for a massive scaling up of support to
the developing countries getting
hammered by the global food crisis
the shipment of grain and other
foodstuffs is crucial
but it won't mean much if countries
cannot afford them
developed countries and international
financial institutions
must do more to ensure that developing
countries can fully capitalize on the
opportunities of the black sea grant
initiative
mr president
despite progress on humanitarian front
fighting in ukraine shows no signs of
ending with new potential areas of
dangerous escalation appearing
two places were ever present in my mind
and in my discussions in ukraine
zaporizia
and orenivka
i remain gravely concerned about the
situation in and around europe's largest
nuclear power plant in zaporizia
the warning lights are flashing
any actions that might endanger the
physical integrity safety or security of
the nuclear plant are simply
unacceptable
any further escalation of the situation
could lead to self-destruction
security of the plant must be ensured
and the plant must be re-established as
purely civilian infrastructure
in close contact with the iaea
the u.n secretariat has assessed that we
have in ukraine the logistics and
security capacity to support any iaea
mission to the zaporizian nuclear power
plant from kiev
provided both russia and ukraine agree
and i welcome expressions of support for
such a mission and urge that to happen
as soon
as possible
mr president i am deeply disturbed by
the allegations of violations of
international humanitarian law
and violations and abuses of human
rights related to the armed conflict
international humanitarian law protects
prisoners of war
the international committee of the red
cross must have access to them wherever
they are held
the united nations human rights
monitoring mission in ukraine and the
u.n independent international commission
of the inquiry on ukraine
continued to mourn monitor document and
report with the view to supporting the
investigation of alleged violations
worse is also ongoing to deploy the
recently established fact-finding
mission to ole rivka to look into the
incident on 29 july
this mission must be able to freely
conduct its work to gather and analyze
necessary information and to find the
facts
it is imperative that the mission has
safe secure and unfettered access to all
relevant places and persons and to our
relevant evidence without any limitation
impediment or interference
mr president excellencies
on this 31st anniversary of ukraine's
independence i wish to congratulate
ukrainian people
the people of ukraine and beyond need
peace and they need peace now
is in line with evan charter
peace in line with international law and
i thank you
i thank the
secretary general
for his introductory remarks
i now
give the floor to ms dicarlo
mr president on 23 february 2022
this chamber heard impassioned pleas to
avert a war in ukraine
to no avail
today exactly six months later there is
no end in sight to the conflict
triggered by the russian federation's
invasion
as we meet the heaviest fighting is
concentrated in the eastern dunbas
region
in the south near her son in zappo asia
and in the northeast near harkeef but
virtually all corners of ukraine are
affected and no one is out of reach of
missile strikes
at the same time several attacks
conducted mainly with drones have also
been reported in the autonomous republic
of crimea and the city of sevastopol
ukraine
occupied by the russian federation since
2014.
president civilians are paying a heavy
price in this war
during the past 181 days the office of
the high commissioner for human rights
has recorded 13
560 civilian casualties
five thousand sixteen six hundred
fourteen killed and seven thousand nine
hundred forty six injured
these figures are based on verified
incidents
actual numbers are considerably higher
the majority of civilian casualties were
caused by explosive weapons with wide
area effects
the use of these weapons in and around
populated areas has predictable and
devastating
consequences
to date ohchr has documented damage
destruction or use for military purposes
of 249 medical facilities and 350
educational facilities
actual figures may be higher
the indiscriminate shelling and bombing
of populated areas killing civilians and
wrecking hospital schools and other
civilian infrastructure are actions that
may amount to war crimes
mr president we continue to receive
reports of human rights violations
the arbitrary detention and enforced
disappearance of civilians including
local authorities journalists civil
society activists and other civilians
continues
ohchr has documented 327 cases of
arbitrary detention and enforced
disappearance of civilians by the
russian federation and affiliated armed
groups in non-government-controlled
territory
ohchr has also recorded 39 arbitrary
arrests in ukrainian
government-controlled territory and 28
other cases they may amount to enforce
disappearance
14 victims of enforced disappearances
perpetrated by the russian federation
and affiliated armed groups were found
dead or died while in detention thirteen
men and one woman
ohchr has also corroborated allegations
of hundreds of willful killings of
civilians while par parts of kiev
journey heath and sumi regions under
russian control in february to march
2022
it has also verified 43 cases of
conflict-related sexual violence the
majority attributable to russian armed
forces
mr president we're also concerned about
the situation of prisoners of war on
both sides
all prisoners of war are protected under
international humanitarian law
there's a need for unimpeded and
confidential access by the international
committee of the red cross
to all places of detention
including to places of internment of
ukrainian prisoners of war and civilian
tink chinese in the russian federation
we are concerned by reports that the
russian federation and affiliated armed
groups in donetsk are planning to try
ukrainian prisoners of war in a
so-called international tribunal and
marijuana
any tribunal must respect the
protections afforded to all prisoners of
war by international law
including fair trial guarantees
the failure to uphold these standards
could amount to a war crime
mr president humanitarian needs continue
to rise rapidly
at least 17.7 million people or 40
percent of the ukrainian population need
humanitarian assistance and protection
including 3.3 million children
humanitarian access is of great concern
roads are heavily contaminated with
explosive ordinance putting civilians at
risk and stopping humanitarian convoys
from reaching
them over 6.6 million
internally displaced persons have been
recorded
another 6.7 million people have left
ukraine to other countries in europe
most of them women and
mr president as winter approaches the
destruction caused by war combined with
the lack of access to fuel or
electricity due to damaged
infrastructure
could become a matter of life or death
if people are unable to heat their homes
an estimated 1.7 million people are
already in need of urgent assistance
with heating shelter repair and other
winterization preparation
as temperatures in parts of the country
are expected to decline to minus 20
degrees celsius
the un's ongoing winterization efforts
aim to complement and support the work
led by the government of ukraine
our revised flash appeal requires 4.3
billion dollars to support 17.7 million
people in need of assistance through
december 2022.
donors have generously provided 2.4
billion as of 19 august
the humanitarian responses scaled up
to 500 humanitarian organization
partners reaching over 11.8 million
people with at least one form of
assistance
the war has severely impacted
agriculture in ukraine leaving thousands
of farmers without income
destroying grain storage facilities and
exacerbating food insecurity among
vulnerable groups
according to the world food program 20
of the people of ukraine have
insufficient food
as a sec mr president as the secretary
general emphasized the repercussions of
the war in ukraine are being felt
worldwide
according to world food program
estimates
345 million people will be acutely food
insecure
or at high risk of food insecurity in 82
countries with a wfp operational
presence
this represents an increase of 47
million acutely hungry people due to the
riffle effects of the war in ukraine
last month undp estimated that up to 71
million people may have already been
pushed into poverty in the three months
after the start of the war
key affected areas include the balkans
the caspian sea region and sub-saharan
africa particularly the sahel
the global financial situation remains
volatile with concerns about potential
stagflation scenarios in the latter part
of 2022 and 2023
and injury markets remain under stress
a serious concern as the winter season
in the northern hemisphere approaches
while food prices have stabilized in
recent weeks this is not necessarily
translated into lower inflation rates
yet
inflation continued to accelerate in
july of this year
it is breaking multi-decade records in
developed countries and yet it is
developing countries and ldcs that have
been more drastically affected
the fiscal situation in many developing
economies is a particular concern
particularly as their borrowing ability
has been fragile following the need to
respond to the covid19 pandemic with
significant expenditures
today developing country debts and
import bills are coming under further
pressure
we remain concerned that the
deteriorating socio-economic situation
in developing countries particularly
those in already fragile situations
could lead to social unrest
while it is difficult to establish a
direct link to the war we have already
seen an increase in the number of riots
between the first and second quarter of
2022
mr president today's grim six-month
anniversary coincides with ukraine's
national day this is an occasion to
celebrate the country's sovereignty and
independence and proud heritage and we
congratulate the people of ukraine on
this day
but let us recall that the human and
material toll of this war is tragic
colossal and evident
first and foremost for ukraine and its
people
economic consequences for the world are
ominous and growing
the conflict is having another impact
that although less tangible is just as
perilous
in deepening global divisions and
exacerbating mistrust in our
institutions the war is weakening the
foundations of our international system
the consequences of a breakdown and how
the world manages questions of peace and
security are frightening to contemplate
this war is not only senseless but
exceedingly dangerous and it touches all
of us it must end
thank you mr president
i thank uh mr carlo for her statement
i now invite
the his excellency mr mullins vladimir
zelinski president of ukraine to give
him the floor
[Music]
thank you to everyone thank you for this
support and greetings from the
independent and free ukraine for the
fight for its
era
just recently as i was preparing for
this statement i've received information
russia has launched missiles against the
nipper petrovsk region against the
railroad station the railroad car cars
at this station
people and if people
were uh
injured unfortunately the death toll
could increase this is the our life
every day this is how russia got
prepared for this u.n session ladies and
gentlemen mr president misters general
secretary
you and
all those
the un charter today our country
celebrate
the day the independence day
and now everyone if you can see how much
in the world is dependent on our
independence
and
whether ukraine is at peace whether our
people are safe whether the integrity of
our territory and the availability of
our borders are guaranteed it can take
any aspect of this terrible
against us and each of these aspects
will be related to one or another global
crisis
now what is happening right now russia
has put the world on the brink of
radiation catastrophe it is a fact that
the russian military has turned the
territory of the largest nuclear power
plant in europe this apparition nuclear
power plant into a war zone this is a
fact
the russia's armed provocation shelling
deployment of terrorists on the
territory of the station under the
russian flag
now
europe and neighboring regions face the
threat of the radiation pollution this
is a fact
now
what is the chernobyl the zapurigin
nuclear power plant
has six reactors
only one reactor exploded in chernobyl
the iaea mission
should take permanent control of the
situation at this upper region nuclear
plant as soon as possible and russia
should unconditionally stop nuclear
blackmail and completely withdraw from
the station russia has
found
hunger it is a fact that russian
blockade of ukrainian ports
and as of increase the deficit
in the already
destabilized food market and
this
situation in different parts of our
planet
let alone
the
drought in europe the largest over the
last 500 years fortunately we've managed
to create
russia was forced to accept the terms of
international community allowing to
restore grain export from three
ukrainian ports
it relieves a part of the tension in the
food market but does not remove the
threat completely only the full recovery
of ukrainian agricultural experts
without any obstacles can be a guarantee
that tens of millions of people around
the world would have something to it
and
aren't you feel resent to the fact that
even now in the 21st century you still
have to fight to save tens of millions
of people in different countries from
this artificial hunger
this artificial one which was provoked
by a single country
with its insane aggression and that's
also in fact
ukraine's
do feel that the uan was established not
to debate in the 21st century over the
aspects that should have long remained
in the past
but nevertheless i thank
mr
secretary general of the un
and the turkey yeah and to the president
of the turkey and to all other
responsible members of international
relations who are fighting against the
food crisis
to which
only russia is responsible in the coming
weeks we have to do everything to expand
the existing grain initiative
let's take another
aspect the energy it is a fact that
russia is deliberately trying to
impose energy poverty upon tens of
millions of people deprive them of
normal access to basic goods
by deliberately raising energy prices
all this is done by a permanent member
to the u.n security council who still
uses the privilege of its veto right the
energy crisis for europe the threat of
large-scale hunger the political chaos
for african and asian countries the
prize crisis in the whole world isn't it
too much
for a single country whose
representative
sits in mongoo i will mention one more
aspect the values
indeed we should honestly talk
about the point that values are
perceived differently in different parts
of the world there's different
approaches but everywhere in the world
life has value
peace has value
economic prosperity has value
all countries if they respect themselves
and their
people punish
for murder and not honor the
executioners however we see that there
is a country that is
not behaves differently and is proud of
doing
so it rewards murderers and encourages
executioners and this is a threat not
only for ukraine salvants of ukrainians
were killed by the russian invaders
dozens of our cities were destroyed by
russian artillery russia
does not comply with fundamental
conventions on the prisoners of war this
is something that was also mentioned
today the deliberate killing by the
russian occupiers of our prisoners of
war in old nifka
one of the most terrible pages in the
history of europe and there is an
immediate need for a unm fact-finding
mission in lenivka and the mandate of
which should be extended to cover all
ukrainian pows currently held by russian
forces there is no such war crime
that the russian occupiers have not yet
committed on the territory of ukraine
but if russia is not stopped now
and in ukraine if it's not stopped
by the victory of ukraine then all these
russian murderers
will inevitably end up
in other countries
europe asia africa latin america
there are traces of russian war
criminals everywhere and we must all get
united and act decisively as soon as
possible
so there are no more traces of russian
missiles
radiation catastrophe every ever again
russia must release the captured
territory of ukraine so that there would
be no food crisis
russia would need to withdraw from our
land
from our sea
so that no country in the world
can ever again disregard
the un
and
conventions binding on all mankind
right there's no
ex
russia must be held accountable for the
crime of aggression against ukraine
the relevant resolution will be
submitted for the consideration of the
77th session of the un general assembly
in order for a sense of justice to
return to international relations we
must all confirm and force russia to
recognize that the inviolability of
borders and peace are unconditional
values for all nations
this is why the independence and
integrity of our country are of
fundamental importance for the
international relations preserving our
independence
guarantee
and returning
normal economic ties with ukraine will
restore the true power to the u.n
charter and save the world
from the crisis
that we're all forced to face now
mr general secretary antonio gutierrez
has the ambitious intention of
organizing the summit of the future next
year
we support this initiative
and reaffirm that in order to build the
future it's necessary to leave in the
dustbin of history what has always
prevented humanity from leaving in peace
namely the aggression
and colonial ambitions that is what
russia has came with to ukraine and i
believe that we can surely build the
future
that would be good
and symbolic
to have this summit in ukraine it is on
the territory of ukraine
that the world's future is decided
whether we will have a future at all
this is being decided
also at the zaparis nuclear power plant
and in our seaports and in donbas and in
the crimea our
independence is your security
the security of the entire
for this opportunity for the
understanding of my situation for the
situation of our country thank you for
the attention and i thank the chinese
presidency
to participate in this session in the
online format glory to you
i thank his excellency mr zelinski for
his statement
i now give the floor to the members of
the security council i give the floor to
the representative of the us
thank you mr president
and thank you secretary general guterres
and under secretary
general de carlo for your briefings
i would also like to congratulate
ukrainians on their independence day
and thank president zielenski for
participating in this meeting today
president zielinski the united states
stands with you and the people of
ukraine today and every day
and every russian bomb that falls only
strengthens our resolve to support your
sovereignty and your independence
today marks
six months of russia's premeditated
unjustifiable
and brutal full-scale war against
ukraine
just six months
since we
sitting here in the council chamber
watched as russia
serving in the presidency attempted to
defend the indefensible
six months of russia's defiance of the
international community
six months of russia's flagrant lies in
disregard for international law
including violations of the u.n charter
six months of attacks by russia killing
ukrainian civilians and strong
destroying civilian civilian
infrastructure
six months of devastation and missile
strikes that have torn apart families
and stolen the lives of too many
like the life of four-year-old lisa
dimitrieva
killed last month in a missile strike
that left 24 people dead
six months of horrific atrocities
including rape murder and torture in
towns like bucha and urpin and others
six months of families being separated
and millions displaced
six months of killings
thousands dead
six months later
russia's goal is as clear as ever
to dismantle ukraine as a geopolitical
entity and erase it from the world world
map
russian disinformation campaigns are
increasingly being weaponized to prepare
for further attempts to annex ukrainian
territory
russian minister of foreign affairs
lavrov publicly acknowledged this as one
of the kremlin's objectives
specifically russia is laying groundwork
to attempt to annex the regions of
hersen and zaparizia and all of the
donetsk and hans oblast
let's be clear
the international community will never
recognize russia's attempt
to change ukraine's borders by force
and when the world's leaders come to new
york next month to reaffirm their
commitments to the u.n charter they are
also reforming their support
for that basic principle
so no matter how many more sham
referendums illegitimate authorities
moscow tries to install we will continue
to defend the u.n charter and uphold
ukraine's sovereignty territorial
integrity and independence
and as we discussed yesterday
russia is responsible for creating
another grave risk to another core
commitment by the international
community to nuclear safety
ukraine had an impeccable record of
nuclear energy safety and security at
the zapariza nuclear power plant
but russia recklessly attacked and
seized control of this plant by force
risking nuclear disaster
in a similar vein we are particularly
concerned by russia's so-called
filtration operations which involve the
systematic forced deportations of
ukrainian civilians to remote areas of
russia
these camps are abducting and separating
children
from their parents
russian forces are forcibly confiscating
and replacing passports
dictating curriculums in schools and
replacing ukrainian street names and
other public signs with russian language
alternatives
the evidence of russian forces
interrogating
detaining and forcibly deporting
hundreds of thousands of ukrainians
including children continue to mount
the reasons are clear
they want to destroy ukraine
it's culture
it's people its very existence
even where we have seen progress like
the movement of grain and other food
stuff from ukrainian ports following the
much needed arrangements signed with
turkey
russia did not let us forget about its
intentions
mere hours
hours after the deal was inked russia
launched missiles at the port of odessa
those missiles were a potent reminder
millions of ukrainians are still
under siege
and tens of millions around the world
are being driven to hunger by russia's
actions
for all this violence and carnage
these hunger and humanitarian crises
these human rights abuses and threats
to vulnerable groups
russia
and russia alone
bears so responsibility
and russia alone
is the sole hindrance to a swift
resolution to this crisis
we must continue to call for and ensure
accountability for all of russia's
atrocities
today marks six months of the war
but it also marks ukraine's independence
day
a day normally celebrated by parades
with festivals with joy
many of us came together in a similar
kind of celebration on july 4th last
month on the u n lawn as america
celebrated its independence
and we ate and we danced and we looked
in awe at the fireworks in the sky
in ukraine today
there are none of the typical festivals
no feast or concerts citizens have been
told to stay away from cities and to
look for very different kinds of
explosions from the sky and we heard
president zielinski describe just that
to us today
one ukrainian citizen told an npr
reporter that she hopes that and i'll
quote her
she hopes that we can celebrate
independence without weapons in the
future
maybe with flowers and dances instead
let us do everything we can to bring the
flowers and the dances back to kiev
back to ukrainians
and let us pray by this time next year
her dream has come true
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of the u.s
for their statement i give the floor to
the representative of albania
thank you mr president and let me also
thank vsg and usg dicarlo for their
update information
31 years ago today
ukraine declared its independence from
the decaying soviet union
it is a day to celebrate and i'm sure
despite the situation ukrainians in
ukraine and abroad
will proudly mark their day in a way or
another
we join them in this and welcome you
president zilensky in this meeting under
the exceptional circumstances you and
your country continue to endure
but celebrations are not easy and hardly
joyful when you are under attack by your
neighbor that pretends
from down to dusk to be your brother
but that kind of brother that is
assaulting you killing your people
destroying your homes bombarding your
cities abusing your women deporting your
people breaking your country denying
your existence
that abusive brother that wants to take
everything you have
mr president
today marks also exactly six months from
the start of the invasion today when the
u.n charter was thrown in the
kremlin shredder
when the term respect for international
law lost any meaning in moscow
it marks 27 weeks from the adoption of
the united nations general assembly
resolution
when the whole world but four
asked russia to stop the war and respect
the sovereignty of ukraine
it marks 25 weeks from illegally binding
order of the international court of
justice
the highest international court
addressed to russia to immediately stop
military activities
all these calls and documents continue
to be ignored
russia persists it's in its course with
a clear intention to dismantle ukraine
and subjugate its people
despite unquestionable evidence and hard
proof
that its actions haven't continued to
produce serious global destabilizing
effects on security energy food
including the risk of a nuclear
catastrophe and are increasingly
decoupling russia from the rest of the
european continent
we welcome
we commend turkey and the secretary
general for their tireless and
successful efforts in making sure that
grain and other food products are
exported from ukraine and go on the
tables of the needy throughout the world
colleagues
the war is having a terrible negative
impact on everything in ukraine and
beyond but hardly anything compares with
the devastating impact on civilians in
general and their children in particular
the future generation
some 1 000 children maybe more will not
be there to see the liberated ukraine
they have been killed
five every day
5.2 million are in need of humanitarian
assistance
3.6 million have been affected by the
closure of schools so by the impact of
attack on schools which will continue to
delay
the children's return to in-person
learning
many more millions are left with
invisible wounds that must be addressed
without delay to prioritize children's
mental health and psychological needs
and help them build resilience
if there were one single reason to put
an immediate end to this war it is this
to save children
the future generations from the scourge
of war as it is written in our
constitution
mr president
a few weeks ago a deadly explosion
killed 53 ukrainian prisoners of war
held in ukraine territory under the
russian control
this tragic event is still not
independently elucidated
and for
as for everything of that nature we are
told that ukraine did it
prisoners of war should have been
protected by law as well as by the
guarantees given to the un and the
international committee for red cross
that the azov daytonis would be properly
treated
unfortunately 53 of them were killed
we welcomed the appointment of the
investigation team by the secretary
general we strongly ask the un to do
everything to make sure that the
investigation is done impartially and on
the u.n terms
those responsible for such despicable
crimes must be held accountable
mr president
with the regular army stretched thin
after six months of a disastrous and
bloody invasion of ukraine there is
increasing in evidence that the kremlin
is making dreadful choices and
recruiting russia's prisoners to fight
credible reports and meticulously and
meticulous investigations point into
that direction
this is very worrying in a situation
that is already alarming since when we
have seen what regular soldiers were
able to execute in bucha
we have shivers thinking about what may
happen when you give weapons to
murderers and criminals who should be
behind bars in russia and not in ukraine
in military uniform
these new fighters if that proves true
will fill in for those who have come to
census
discovered the truth and abandoned the
war not to continue to be partners in
crime like pavel filatiev
he was sent to cursin
he is free to speak his mind now and
tell his story and what is he saying
let me quote
we understood that we were dragged into
a serious conflict where we are simply
destroying towns and not actually
liberating anyone
we do not see any reason that our
government is trying to explain to us
all of it is a lie
we are just destroying peaceful lives
and of course
his account is much longer 141 pages
out there in the open for everyone to
read the immense despair of someone sent
to commit crimes next door
mr president
we have warned before and wish to
reiterate particularly on this day
any territory territory annexation any
development incompatible with ukraine
constitution imposed by russia
such as sham elections or
alarus
will not be accepted will not be
recognized
russian officials in the territories and
the russian control speak openly of
joining russia by implementing the
crimea template
this will be known void at that end
as stated by key european leaders as
recently as yesterday
ukraine france are ready to support
ukraine's fight to defend itself
not because anyone is against russia and
the russians but simply because all
those who are for pc in ukraine the
litmus test of the european security
architecture and the stress test of
resilience of world peace and security
in front of long gone imperial behavior
colleagues
on this day we reaffirm once more our
full and unwavering solidarity with the
people of ukraine
we pay tribute to all those who are
fighting to defend their land and their
lives and to all those sacrificed for
the independence and freedom of ukraine
we reiterate our support for the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders
and we call on russia to stop the war
withdraw its troops and change course
so that next year at this time there is
a real happy parade in kiev
not the one with the burnt out or
abundant husks of russian military
equipment
the epitome of this senseless war and i
thank you
i thank the representative of albania
for their statement i now give the floor
to the representative france
thank you to the secretary general and
mr carlo for their briefings
and i would also like to welcome the
briefing provided by president zielenski
this morning mr president
for exactly six months now ukrainians
have courageously resisted the war of
aggression launched by russia with its
horrific toll of mass suffering and
abuse
need we recall that ukrainians are
fighting for their sovereignty and the
territorial integrity of their country
what better time to pay tribute than
today the day of their national holiday
which in 1991 marked the independence of
ukraine
through its struggle ukraine is also
defending the purposes and principles of
the u.n charter and that is why france
will continue to stand by its side with
our european partners we will continue
to support ukraine as long as is
necessary in the face of russian
aggression
on this day when ukrainian independence
is celebrated let me say clearly again
that france will never recognize the
annexation of territories occupied by
the russian federation france will not
recognize the legitimacy of independent
referenda organized by russia in these
territories in an attempt to legitimize
its aggression and camouflage its
flagrant violations of international law
nor have we ever recognized nor will we
ever recognize the annexation of crimea
mr president with this war russia is
further destabilizing
the world already grappling with serious
threats we welcome the fact that the
joint coordination center in istanbul is
now operational and that 33 vessels have
been able to leave ukrainian ports since
the signing of the istanbul
accords
but let us not delude ourselves the
negative fallout of the
war led by russia is ongoing and is
getting worse supply chains are still
disrupted
transportation costs remain very high
the energy markets are crippled
as long as russian aggression persists
the fallout will continue to spread
the presence of russian troops on the
zaporiza nuclear power plant also
heightens the risk of nuclear accident
with potentially devastating
consequences
we recall our appeal for the withdrawal
of russian forces any incident
would be the primary responsibility of
russia and it is crucial for the iaea to
be able to conduct expert missions on
the ground as soon as possible mr
president the information we have
received about extrajudicial executions
acts of torture against ukrainian
prisoners in particular in the olympic
village but not just there beyond it as
well is shocking let us repeat
russia must respect
international humanitarian law that
applies in all international armed
conflicts whether or not it acknowledges
being at war as well as international
human rights law
france along with its partners rallied
in the initial days of russian
aggression to ensure that the authors of
crimes committed in ukraine would be
identified found in their crimes
documented we actively support the work
of the international criminal court
investigating crime
acts which may
constitute
war crimes crimes of genocide or crimes
against humanity we also support
investigations of ukrainian
jurisdictions we will follow closely
the upcoming publication by the
international independent
commission of inquiry created by the
human rights council with the support of
france once again we call upon russia to
choose diplomacy to rebuild peace with
ukraine to recognize its sovereignty and
territorial integrity in internationally
recognized borders at the time and under
the conditions determined by ukrainians
which are is the victim of aggression
france will continue to commit itself to
that end thank you
i thank the representative france for
the statement and i'll give the floor to
the representative of ireland thank you
mr president and i would like to thank
the secretary general for his remarks
and indeed his efforts with regards to
resolving the war in ukraine and its
wider consequences including for global
food security i also thank usg de carlo
for her briefing and i want to welcome
president zielenski's address to the
council and reiterate ireland's
unwavering friendship and support to the
people of ukraine on the occasion of
their independence day
mr president it is eight and a half
years since russia first violated the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
it is six months to the day since russia
launched its further illegal unprovoked
invasion of ukraine
violating and attacking the core
principles of this united nations
yet let us be clear
the internationally recognized borders
of ukraine have not changed in the last
six months nor in the last eight and a
half years
the decision by ukraine to invade the
decision by russia to invade ukraine has
not changed those borders
they did not change in 2014 and they
have not changed in 2022
neither will unilateral steps by russia
to integrate parts of ukraine be
recognized for anything other than
flagrant violations of the principles of
sovereign independence and
non-intervention
and a bold attempt to entrench a
supposed sphere of influence
we also condemn the dangerous escalatory
and unacceptable nuclear
rhetoric by russia during this conflict
mr president for 183 days ireland has
called for an end to the unjustified and
unjustifiable war being waged against
ukraine
as each day passes
reports of violations of human rights
and international humanitarian law by
russia grow
civilians in ukraine continue to pay the
highest price
for six months they have been living
under terror
not knowing when and where the next bomb
will strike
we therefore once again call on russia
to comply with his obligations under
international law
parties of the conflict must comply with
international humanitarian law
they have an obligation to distinguish
between civilians and combatants and not
to attack civilian objects
there is a prohibition against
indiscriminate and disproportionate
attacks
and an obligation to take all feasible
precautions in attack
and compliance is not optional
mr president as i said yesterday at our
meeting ireland remains extremely
concerned by the situation at the
zaparia nuclear power plant and the
serious risk of a radiological accident
or incident arising from military
activity at the start with devastating
consequences
we call on russia to end its illegal
occupation of the site withdraw its
troops and munitions and ensure that the
ukrainian authorities can uphold their
responsibilities for safety and security
at the site we welcome reports that a
visit by the iaea could go ahead soon
and support the secretary general's call
for the plant to remain connected to the
ukrainian power grid
mr president once again we call on
russia to end its brutal war and
withdraw its troops from the entire
internationally recognized territory of
ukraine and to respect the sovereignty
and territorial integrity of its
neighbors
russia can end its aggression if it
chooses
but even while it chooses to execute its
illegal war it still has obligations
under international law and it must
comply with those obligations
we note this morning the comments from
the secretary general and the un
secretary
and the under secretary general on
humanitarian need particularly in the
face of the onset of winter
russia's aggression continues to cause
mounting hardship and suffering for the
people of ukraine who have shown
remarkable resilience and result
today ireland stands in full solidarity
with them thank you
well guys here ireland
i thank the representative of ireland
for their statement i'll give the floor
to the referendum in norway
thank you mr president
russia's war in ukraine is affecting us
all
it is an attack on democratic values and
on freedom
it's causing a global food crisis and
it's a blatant violation of
international law and the very
principles of the u.n charter
to president zielinski thank you for
your strong testimony this morning and
for the heroic fight you and the
ukrainian people are engaged in for your
country and for peace and freedom of us
all
today we mark the ukrainian declaration
of independence in 1991
and here we are 31 years later because
the soviet successor state russia has
invaded ukraine
it's truly tragic
so we reiterate our unwavering support
for ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
usg de carlo thank you for your
thorough and thoughtful briefing
and secretary general thank you for your
briefing including on your important
recent visit to ukraine
norway applauds your crucial role in the
black sea grain initiative and your
further tireless efforts to alleviate
the consequences of this horrible war
and to restore peace
president norway condemns the russian
military aggression in the strongest
terms possible
russia's warfare in urban and populated
areas and the use of heavy explosive
weapons is destroying homes schools
and hospitals
and the ongoing attacks on civilians and
civilian infrastructure including
nuclear power plants is having a
devastating and unacceptable impact
thousands of civilians have already been
killed
millions have fled their homes others
are trapped in war zones
we stand with the people all over
ukraine who continue to live in daily
fear of the next attack
and we reiterate our demand that
civilians must be protected and
international humanitarian law and
international human rights law fully
respected and implemented
humanitarian actors must be insured
access
russia must stop the war and fully
immediately and unconditionally withdraw
its forces and military equipment from
ukraine
russia started the war in ukraine it can
choose to stop it
it seems clear that war crimes are being
committed
these cannot be forgotten
perpetrators on all levels
must be held accountable
president
the secretary general has talked about
the beacon of hope with the resumption
of ukrainian grain exports
we are encouraged that the critical
transportation line from a global
breadbasket might be restored
it is much needed for ukrainians as well
as the world's most vulnerable people
and countries
and it is critical that the world food
programme and other humanitarian actors
again can purchase grain from ukraine
for humanitarian food assistance
it is now vital that the black sea grain
initiative is fully implemented
president the accumulated effects on the
war are felt by more people every day
in may this council expressed its
unified support for the efforts of the
secretary general in the search for a
peaceful solution
we must continue to support the
secretary general in his efforts for
dialogue and mediation between the
parties
in the search for peace and freedom for
the people of ukraine
and we stress the joint responsibility
of the members of this council to make
every effort to ensure peace
again to the ukrainian people
our thoughts are with you on your
national day
and every other day we reiterate our
solidarity with you i thank you
i thank the representative of norway for
their statement i give the floor to the
representative of the united kingdom
thank you president
on behalf of the united kingdom i thank
the secretary general and under
secretary general de carlo for their
briefings
we warmly welcome president zielenski's
participation in today's meeting
six months ago
even as this council met late into the
night to try to avert catastrophe
russia launched an unprovoked and
illegal invasion of ukraine in violation
of the u.n charter
in the months that followed ukraine has
been subjected to the full horrors of
war we've heard today
thousands of civilians have been killed
or wounded
over 17 million are now in need of
humanitarian assistance
schools hospitals and other medical
facilities
have been attacked
we have seen a pattern of russian
violations of international humanitarian
law
and of russian human rights abuses and
violations including reports of torture
inhumane treatment and arbitrary
detention
ukrainian citizens including children
have been forcibly deported
to russia
six million people are displaced within
ukraine and over six million are
refugees abroad
and the people of ukraine are not the
only victims of this war
beyond ukraine's borders
putin's decisions have had a devastating
impact on the world's most vulnerable
with many millions across the world
affected by rising food and fuel prices
we again pay tribute to the work of the
u.n secretary general with turkey
to negotiate the black sea grain
initiative
president
today in what would be another violation
of the un charter there are reports that
russia is planning fake referenda to
illegally annex more territory from
ukraine
any such attempt would fool no one
russia has
after all
lied throughout their illegal invasion
using disinformation to create false
pretexts
undermine ukrainian sovereignty
obscure the truth
and hide war crimes
and it would further demonstrate
russia's contempt for the principles of
sovereignty and territorial integrity
principles which
as member states of this organization
we have all committed to upholding
president 31 years ago today
ukraine declared its independence
with over 90 of ukrainians voting in
favor
today
that pride in ukrainian identity and
sovereignty remains as strong as ever
we have all seen the courage and
ingenuity of the ukrainian people
as they have fought to defend their
nation against russia's attack on their
national sovereignty
and right to self-determination
ukraine's fight is a fight for the
principles of the un charter
all of us in this chamber have a
responsibility to recognize that
it is a fight that has inspired the
world with its courage and defiance
against brutality
so today
on ukrainian independence day
we stand together with unite with the
nation of ukraine
and its heroic people
who continue to resist russia's attempts
to rewrite international borders by
force
we once again call for russia to
withdraw its forces from ukraine
immediately
and we call for full accountability
for russia's crimes
thank you
i thank the representative of the uk for
their statement give the floor to the
representative of brazil
thank you mr president
i acknowledge the participation in the
session of his excellency president
zelinski to whom i extend
congratulations
on the occasion
of ukraine's national day
i thank the secretary general and usg
rosemary de carlo for their remarks
six months after the opening of
hostilities
there seems to be no solution in sight
for the conflict in ukraine
the situation is now compounded by the
risk of nuclear disaster
it is essential that the parties refrain
from attacks
that could threaten the safety of
nuclear facilities
as has been happening in the vicinity of
the zaporizia plant
brazil reiterates the call for the two
sides to facilitate the access of an
iaea mission so that conditions of the
plant can be properly evaluated
it is deeply saddening to note
how little progress has been made
towards a political solution
the most notable result was the
initiative on grain exports from
ukrainian ports
and on facilitating russian grain and
fertilizer exports
announced in july
for which we are grateful to the efforts
of the secretary general and the support
of the government of turkey
when the party is engaged in
negotiations an important result was
achieved
which partly alleviates the effects of
the conflict on food prices around the
world
and particularly in developing countries
mr president
reality and history
show
that closing the door to dialogue is not
the right approach to resolving any any
conflict
and this applies to ukraine
actions that prolong the hostilities
will only result in greater human
suffering and will not resolve the
underlying causes
brazil welcomes the secretary general's
efforts to ensure the implementation of
the istanbul agreements and takes note
of his visit to the region last week
it is essential that the international
community seek to preserve this
important achievement
which indicates a possible path towards
broader negotiations
we urge the parties to keep open the
channels of dialogue that made possible
the istanbul package
as they offer the best prospects for
peace
finally we recall the obligation of both
sides under international humanitarian
law
to protect the civilian population
and prevent human rights abuses
attacks against residential areas and
facilities such as schools churches and
hospitals are unacceptable and fuel a
logic of retaliation
that must be avoided by all means
it is in everyone's interest that the
two countries can live peacefully
side by side in the future and cooperate
to achieve the development goals
i thank you mr president
i thank the representative of brazil for
his statement i'll give the floor to the
representative of gabon
thank you mr president
i thank the secretary general antonio
guterres
and under secretary general rosemary de
carlo for their respective briefings
i welcome the participation
of
president of ukraine in today's meeting
mr president
as the war in ukraine enters its seventh
month
our hearts are full of compassion
for all the civilian victims since the
beginning of the conflict we
express our solidarity with the
survivors among whom our many women
children and older persons displaced
persons and refugees
whose daily lives have been upturned
we pay tribute
to the humanitarian personnel who work
on the ground to
alleviate the atrocities of daily life
for survivors of the war by providing
vital
precious aid often in difficult
conditions
in addition to
the human told of the word there is a
very heavy material toll images of the
destruction of public buildings
communications
and public service distribution channels
have become daily occurrences
targeting nuclear facilities of which
the zaparilla nuclear power plant has
become symbolic
create the risk of nuclear catastrophe
this is a risk that increases
with the further development of military
activity around this site
there is an urgent need for military
activity around nuclear facilities to
cease and for warring parties to refrain
from any action that could put the world
at risk of a nuclear catastrophe
with irreparable consequences
we reiterate
our appeal
to the parties to complying with the
nuclear safety rules in force and to
cooperate with the iaea to secure
potentially dangerous sites
in order to prevent the risk of disaster
we welcome recent announcements
indicating the willingness of the party
parties to allow a mission of iaea
experts
visit the zaparia power plant in order
to avoid any conflagration
we reiterate our opposition to the war
and our outrage
repeating that the parties the conflict
must respect
the international commitments they have
entered into under international
humanitarian law
the most recent update from the office
of the high commissioner for human
rights reports
13 477 civilian
casualties including
five hundred eighty-seven killed and
seven thousand eight hundred and ninety
injured
a large number of civilians including
children
are maimed by explosive weapons with a
large impact area and indiscriminate
effects
for as long as the fighting continues
the humanitarian situation in ukraine
and surrounding countries
will continue to deteriorate
it is hard to
predict the extent of the
physical and psychological repercussions
that will result let alone the economic
consequences whose shockwaves continue
to spread
mr president
for seven months this kind this council
has been plagued by unprecedented
fragmentation it has been living to the
rhythm of invectives of one camp against
the other
while towns and villages are ravaged
women men and children are being scarred
by a bloody wound
our mandate
is to stop wars if not to prevent them
it is urgent for us to
come together around our mandate and the
purpose of this council
faced with the
hopeless logic of confrontation and
antagonism
my country will continue to choose the
side of
this is the unwavering position of my
country which since the beginning of the
hostilities
has stood in favor of consultations as
the preferred method of resolving
conflicts the recent agreement
that was reached to allow the export of
green from ukrainian reports is one ray
of hope that can lead to more at its
high time for peace to return to the
heart of our priorities
my country once again calls on the
parties to firmly commit to negotiations
and good faith
with the goal of silencing the guns and
bringing peace to ukraine thank you mr
president
i thank the representative of gabon for
his statement i give the floor to the
representative of kenya
thank you mr president
i thank secretary general antonio
guterres and under secretary general
rosemary dicarlo for their updates on
the situation in ukraine
kenya takes this opportunity to convey
our best wishes to president zielenski
and the people of ukraine on their
independence day
we regret that what should be a day of
celebration
is impaired by a war that has breached
ukraine's territorial integrity
contrary to the fundamental principles
of the un charter
the people of ukraine have suffered
greatly these past six months
we offer them and particularly the
bereaved families our deepest
condolences
mr president
ukraine's independence day
gives us an opportunity to appreciate
our own independence as i am sure is the
case for every member of this assembly
we will forever be thankful for the
brave men and women who fought for our
freedom
we joined the un within days of becoming
independent
we signed up to its principles
because as a young nation
we needed assurance that our sovereignty
territorial integrity and political
independence would be respected
we valued its mission to outlaw
aggression
to use its instruments to help us turn
our swords into plowshares so that we
could enjoy the fruits of our freedom
we remain thankful that this united
nations stood for decolonization
that it gave voice to the smallest
countries in the world without regard to
their military might or wealth
what a precious heritage we have
and how intolerable
that it should be as endangered as it is
today
we are forced by this moment
to recall how its failed predecessor the
league of nations was unable to stop the
conflicts that led to the great fire of
world war ii
multilateralism as expressed in the
united nations
including in this venerated chamber
with all its flaws
is our last hope against a new world war
the wars we choose to fight as kenya and
africa
as i believe is the case for most of the
world
are for independence from poverty
ignorance and disease
we have no desire
to be drawn into a worldwide conflict
or for our grievances and disagreements
to be the soil in which wars by proxy
take root
we see in ukraine's war a grim warning
that we too may be engulfed by the
competitions and confrontations that are
contributing to its ferocity
that is why we believe that ukraine's
immediate fate
is so important to all of us
ukraine deserves the same freedom and
independence that we enjoy
it is a member of our un in good
standing
its sovereignty territorial integrity
and political independence should be
respected
its people do not deserve to have their
lives and livelihoods destroyed
unless the ukraine war is stopped
through dialogue and negotiation
it could be the first of a series of
conflicts that future historians will
name the third world war
such a disaster would be different from
the last wars and all the wars before
them
the dangers of direct conflict between
nuclear-armed powers
means that most of their confrontations
would be undertaken by proxy
africa and the rest of the world would
be thrown into a mirror of the cold war
that shattered our democracies overthrew
and killed our leaders
and robbed us of decades of economic
progress
stopping this war in a manner that
adheres to the principles of the u.n
charter is what will keep other old
grievances from boiling over
mr president
not all is lost
even in such dark times we must remember
that in the past serious threats to
international peace and security have
been successfully resolved
there is yet a chance to build on the
slim but important success
represented by the agreement between the
parties for the secure export of
ukraine's food products through the
black sea
as well as food and fertilizer exports
from russia
we commend the secretary general and the
government of taqiyy for their crucial
facilitation
the willingness of the parties to
negotiate and the alertness
subtle skill and moral persuasion of the
facilitators demonstrate that diplomacy
is still able to deliver if given a
chance
we cannot leave our fate to the most
powerful
some of them may be bent on domination
but but we cannot allow it to be at the
expense of our common peace
they may project certainty and great
power but none can know or control the
future
it is time for intuitive
bold leadership from any and every
country
that has influence or leverage
to push them to dialogue rather than
confrontation
the immediate aim should be for
cessation of hostilities in ukraine the
opening of safe humanitarian corridors
and unhindered humanitarian access and
the security of all nuclear
installations
especially the zaporiza nuclear power
plant
these should be part of a road map to
achieving a comprehensive agreement that
secures the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine
such an end given the emerging
escalation between the great powers
would ideally be linked to a broader
negotiation that produces a stable
european security order
the principles underlying such an order
should adhere to the un charter
and be utilized to stabilize other parts
of the world
in the meantime kenya while in the
security council and in all relevant
forums will offer every support to
positive efforts seeking these aims
we will continue to champion the cause
of the secretary general and his team
who need to be commended for their
tireless efforts
in this in this regard we applaud his
recent visit to la vie
we also pay tribute to the determined
efforts by the un's agencies funds and
programs to provide humanitarian aid and
comfort to ukraine's most vulnerable
their impact is evidence of a depth of
competence that we hope is resourced and
deployed with equal ambition
in other conflict areas
mr president
we know that even with a gravely
threatened multilateralism
as reflected in this downcast security
council
a spirit of urgency and imagination can
still allow us to forge a just peace for
ukraine
i wish for all ukrainians
their continued independence
as i reaffirmed kenya's respect for
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
i thank you for your attention
i thank the representative of kenya for
his statement now give the floor to the
representative of uae
thank you mr president and at the outset
i would like to thank the secretary
general for his opening remarks and
under secretary general dicarlo for her
valuable briefing
i want to also express our gratitude to
the secretary general and his team for
effective use of his good offices as the
secretary general said in odessa the
ships that left ukrainian ports over the
last month
carrying grain are indeed vessels of
hope
i also thank president vladimir zelensky
of ukraine for his briefing and i'd like
to join my colleagues in congratulating
president zielenski and all ukrainians
for their country's independence day
we mark six months since the beginning
of the war in ukraine and it is
difficult to overstate the toll it has
had the dead the injured for those
remaining in the country and those
forced to flee
a staggering one-third of ukrainians
have been displaced from their homes and
6.6 million have sought refuge across
europe
beyond ukraine's borders the conflict
has exacerbated food insecurity and the
rise in commodity prices both of which
add to the daily hardship suffered by
hundreds of millions of people around
the world
the uae strongly applauds the agreements
brokered with the support of the
secretary general and the republic of
turkey to facilitate the export of grain
food supplies and fertilizers to global
markets
this rare example of tangible progress
cannot however be the last it must
incentivize more concerted efforts to
mitigate the impact of this conflict on
the lives of those most in need and
hopefully ensure that we are not here
six months from now marking a year of
conflict and further global disruption
mr president the u.n charter provides a
repertoire of tools to address the
peaceful settlement of disputes
none of which are applicable in the
absence of the political will to use
them
in turn this requires us all of us to
recognize that the war will only end
through a negotiated settlement
and that all wars must eventually end as
they have done countless times in human
history
there is value in the council's meetings
on ukraine when they're complemented
with action laser focused on alleviating
the suffering of civilians and finding a
political path to this war's end
we cannot change the past but what
happens next is a responsibility we all
share
in the last few weeks we have seen signs
of progress particularly the agreements
on agricultural exports we've also taken
positive note of the party's express
support for the iaea to send a mission
to the zaparizia nuclear power plant and
we urgently reiterate that this must
happen as the secretary general has said
the warning lights are flashing and
failure to act could be grave
these initiatives all have the potential
as confidence-building measures that
could unlock broader political
discussions and we need to work hard to
preserve and expand these windows
towards viable diplomatic initiatives
aimed at de-escalation and resolution
mr president a peaceful sustainable
resolution relies ultimately on the u.n
charter and international law as our
guiding principle
six months in our call for a cessation
of hostilities throughout ukraine is as
relevant as it has ever been
we cannot become inured to this war the
stakes are too high every life is too
precious
the conflict should end now and we need
to see leaders from both sides commit to
charting that difficult path forward
with all of our support thank you mr
president
i thank the representative of uae for
her statement
now i give the floor to the
representative of ghana
i thank you mr president
i welcome the participation in this
meeting of president zelinski
and other group 39 participants
we wish ukraine best wishes on their
independence day
i also expressed thanks to the secretary
general for his pertinent briefing on
the humanitarian and security situation
in ukraine
and join others in commending his direct
involvement in the multiple mediation
efforts aimed at getting the russian
federation and ukraine to seize their
military hostilities and to positively
engage in dialogue
i affirm in that regard ghana's full
support for the continuous deployment of
the sg's good offices in helping to
bring lasting peace to the people of
ukraine
mr president the black sea grain
initiative and the agreement on
promoting the assets of russian food
products and fertilizers to world
markets both secured under the auspices
of the united nations
with the active facilitation by other
key actors have proven that with
persistent diplomacy an acceptable
political solution could be found to the
ongoing military hostilities in ukraine
now more than ever we must seize on the
positive momentum
generated by these two outcomes and
intensify efforts to find other avenues
to significantly diffuse their
dangerously escalating tensions
indeed since the initially on july 27th
and the subsequent implementation the
maritime humanitarian corridor in the
black sea created by the initiative has
enabled more than 500 000 metric tons of
grain and other foodstuffs to be
evacuated from ukraine's south imports
to various parts of the world which hida
too had been reeling under the threat of
hunger and food insecurity
we urge the members of this council to
overcome their persistent divide and
work in a constructive manner to bring
the weight of the council's authority in
support of such initiatives
mr president the mountain death tool and
the distraction to economic
infrastructure in ukraine remain a
matter of deep concern to ghana
the deliberate targeting of nuclear
facilities
meant for peaceful purposes has further
heightened our fears that a dangerous
face has begun in this senseless war
we stress the need for the parties to
heed our genuine cause including that of
the international community to end the
war
further we etched the demilitarization
of all the zones around uk ukraine's
nuclear facilities and our firm our
support for international inspectors to
be allowed access to the facilities in
line with established norms
beyond the fact that there is no
military solution to the substantive
security concerns of the parties the war
is unfortunately accentuating
geopolitical tensions in many areas
exerting further strain on the already
fragile international order
we share the conviction that any
miscalculation could potentially result
in a wider conflict in europe
with long-term irreparable damage to the
global peace and security architecture
we therefore continue to edge maximum
restraints on the part of all the key
actors and for an unconditional respect
of the obligations imposed by the
charter in that regard we encourage all
parties to the conflict to seek pacific
settlement as there should be no
question about the need to respect
international law which underpins the
current rules-based international order
mr president in conclusion
we wish to underscore that it is crucial
for the lives and safety of civilians
particularly women and children caught
up in the ongoing war to be prioritized
above every other consideration
we therefore renew our call on the
russian federation to withdraw all its
invading troops from the internationally
recognized borders of ukraine and pursue
diplomacy and dialogue to resolve its
legitimate security concerns i thank you
cheers
thank you
and i would like to give the flow to the
representative representative of india
mr president
we thank the secretary general for his
comprehensive briefing on his visit to
ukraine last week
we thank usd
de carlo for for her intervention
i also joined my foreign minister in
conveying our greetings today to the
people of ukraine on the occasion of
their independence day
as we meet to mark six months since the
beginning of the ongoing conflict in
ukraine india is ready to dispatch its
12th consignment
of humanitarian aid to ukraine
consisting of 26 types of medicines
including hemostatic bandages meant to
stem the bleeding of deep wounds in
children and adults
this was a specific request by the
ukrainian side and we have made sure
that we we will be reacting in the
fastest possible time to meet this
in the last six months india has
dispatched 11 consignments
of approximately
97.5 tons of humanitarian aid to ukraine
and neighboring countries such as
romania moldova slovakia and poland
ukraine and its neighboring countries
had offered their full support in the
relief and evacuation operation of
around 22
500 indian nationals in february march
this year this humanitarian aid and
assistance symbolizes the human-centric
development approach of the government
of india a central tenet of our national
beliefs and values which perceives the
whole world as one family
india remains deeply concerned over the
situation in ukraine the conflict has
resulted in loss of lives and countless
miseries for its peoples particularly
for women children and the elderly with
millions becoming homeless and forced to
take shelter in neighboring countries
we believe that going forward we need to
focus on the following aspects
one
in terms of diplomacy india continues to
advocate for an immediate cessation of
hostilities and an end to violence
we encourage talks between ukraine and
russia
prime minister narendra modi has himself
more than once spoken to them in this
regard
two the ground situation calls for
sustained prioritization of urgent
humanitarian relief
i have just elaborated that we continue
to give the highest priority to the
requests that we receive in this regard
we also reiterate the importance of the
un-guiding principles of humanitarian
assistance
humanitarian action must always be
guided by the principles of humanitarian
assistance that is humanity neutrality
impartiality and independence these
measures should never be politicized
three
we will work with the international
community and partner countries to
mitigate the economic hardships that are
resulting from this conflict
the impact of the ukraine conflict is
not just limited to europe
exacerbating concerns over food
fertilizer and fuel security
particularly in the developing countries
four food security remains a major
concern it is necessary for all of us to
adequately appreciate the importance of
equity
and accessibility when it comes to food
grains
india has been approached for the supply
of wheat and sugar by many countries
and we are responding positively
in the last three months alone india has
exported more than 1.8 million tons of
wheat to countries in need including to
afghanistan myanmar sudan and yemen
five we are also trying to increase the
production of essential agrarian inputs
like fertilizers in india there is also
a need to focus on the availability of
fertilizers and keep the supply chains
of fertilizer smooth at a global scale
six efforts should be made to ensure
stability in the global supply of fuel
commensurate with demand open markets
must not become an argument to
perpetrate inequity and promote
discrimination
seven
we have delivered for the world in terms
of vaccines
we did it earlier for medicines
so i would like to assure this council
that india will step forward whenever
the global south is constrained on
aspects of food health and energy
security and we will do this in a manner
that is helpful to the global economy
and does not take undue advantage of
countries in distress
to conclude india's approach will be to
promote dialogue and diplomacy with an
overarching aim to end the conflict and
work with other partners to mitigate the
economic challenges emerging from the
russia ukraine conflict mr president
it is in our collective interest to work
constructively both inside the united
nations and outside seeking an early
resolution to this conflict we continue
to reiterate that the global order be
anchored on international law the u.n
charter and respect for the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of states
thank you
i thank the representative of india for
her statement now i give the floor
to the representative of the russian
federation
mr president
regarding the statement by the president
of ukraine the reason
the security council at one point
decided not to involve foreign leaders
by vtc
also lies in
seeking to avoid technical difficulties
which we
just witnessed during mr zielinski's
statement
it was very difficult to make out
anything that was said at all at certain
points
we hope that our position regarding the
usefulness of in-person participation of
guests at the very least out of respect
for them has become clearer
as a result of this to those following
today's meeting
mr president yesterday we gathered here
yesterday in connection with a concrete
threat to international peace and
security namely kiev's ongoing bombing
of the president nuclear power plant
which is putting europe on the brink of
a nuclear catastrophe
we took notes
of the explanations of the secretary
general for why he did not take part in
yesterday's meeting
today's meeting however is formally not
related to developments on the ground at
all and is meant to demonstrate the
unfailing support of western delegations
for
any actions of the kia regime
we have predictably heard plenty of
mantras about russian aggression
as we have already said over the past
200 years no other explanation for
european security issues except for
references to russia's actions has
emerged in the west
today we also heard
many claims about the catastrophic
consequences of six months of
hostilities for the civilian population
of ukraine no one is arguing that it is
difficult for ukrainians today however
the responsibility for this lies with
the kia regime which came to power in
2014 as a result
of an anti-constitutional coup carried
out with the help of a number of western
states from the very beginning the new
maidan authorities
have been steadily leading the country
to disaster choosing the path of
russophobia and the glorification of
nazi criminals
thus according to the most conservative
estimates more than 60 percent of the
population of ukraine was deprived of
the opportunity to realize their
russian-speaking identity contrary to
all
relevant international conventions and
ukraine's obligations
there are western backers blinded by the
geopolitical goal of weakening russia
made it clear from the beginning they
would cover up any crimes committed by
the cave authorities and turn a blind
eye to things
that they would never allow in their own
countries
the kiev regime fully
demonstrated its criminal nature when it
burnt to sensors alive in the house of
trade unions and odessa and dropped
bombs and shells on the civilian
population of dunbas
in this senseless crusade against itself
ukraine lost crimea
and provoked armed resistance from
donetsk and lugansk residents who took
up arms in the name of freedom and the
future of their children
this war
which claimed the lives of civilians for
eight years could have ended if kiev had
fulfilled the minsk agreements
neither the ukrainian authorities nor
their foreign patrons needed this they
openly stated this once again at the
beginning of this year while threatening
to abandon their non-nuclear status
in such a context in order to establish
peace in the donbas and to prevent the
obvious threats to russia emanating from
ukraine we had no choice but to launch a
special operation to de-nazify and
demilitarize ukraine
the goals of which are being
successfully and steadily fulfilled i
repeat once again
if the minsk agreements had been
implemented no special operation would
have been needed
but the regime in kiev decided otherwise
the criminal shelling of the republics
of donbass continues in the donetsk
people's republic
more than 800.
and
40 people estimated to have died on the
line of contact since the beginning of
the escalation in february about 2 800
injured in the lahangs people's republic
80 people were killed and more than 250
were injured approximately 100 civilians
have been killed in just four weeks
since the previous meeting on july 29th
the armed forces of ukraine are
purposefully destroying civilian
infrastructure including kindergarten
schools and medical facilities power
lines and gas
they planes not spare even those cities
in donbass that until recently were
under their control such as chance for
example
and our former western partners instead
of condemning their ukrainian mentees
are supplying them with more and more
new types of weapons
which reach areas that kiev could not
previously reach
in doing this they're becoming
accomplices in crimes against the
civilian population and
given that the use of some artillery
systems as the ukrainians themselves
admit
is impossible without coordinating the
targets with suppliers they are becoming
core perpetrators as well
this primarily concerns the
american
highmars multiple launch rocket systems
which were used for instance to strike
the correctional facility in yelenivka
on july 29th claiming the lives of more
than 50 ukrainian prisoners of war
we know that the president of ukraine is
well aware of the fact
that it is the armed forces of ukraine
who are behind this crime despite
the fact
that he sold us a
false version today of russia being
responsible for this mr president
from the very beginning we warned that
ukrainian armed groups were actively
using civilian facilities for military
purposes
meanwhile local residents are prohibited
from leaving their homes and all their
attempts to independently evacuate to
safe areas are brutally suppressed
there have been so many
incidents of ukrainian artillery and
ammunition being situated on the
territory of educational medical
facilities over these six months that
even pro-western human rights
organizations such as amnesty
international can no longer ignore them
however instead of forcing kiev to
comply with international humanitarian
law our western colleagues after the
tantrum thrown by ukrainian authorities
who are used to getting away with
everything
chose to publicly castigate amnesty
international itself instead
and today ms dicarlo
found words to express concern in
connection with the
upcoming trial of azov nazis and sadist
but said nothing of the
horrific crimes they committed in their
violations of international humanitarian
law including brutal torture information
regarding which
is
available to
the international civil service
community including mr carlo herself
and the united nations has
enough information about this as well
the yuan
ms de carlo represents
this all frankly looks
extremely cynical and
denigrates the values of freedom of
speech and it's a shame that you don't
understand this but ordinary ukrainians
are well aware of this they encounter
the atrocities of the armed forces of
ukraine and the national battalions and
their inhumane methods let me cite just
one example
at the meeting in july we already showed
you a photo of the lepa stock or petal
anti-personnel mine
today for greater clarity i will show
you the training models
for these mines
which ukrainian troops scattered by the
hundreds and the donbas and the
territories liberated by the russian
army and
even throw them into the territory of
russia
imagine such an inconspicuous pedal
lying on the ground in the grass
it can also be camouflage colored which
makes it virtually invisible on the
ground
considering that the ukrainian armed
forces scatter these mines and towns and
villages far behind the front lines it
is not soldiers that they pose a threat
to at all no they are purposefully
designed
to target civilians especially children
who risk stepping on them or picking up
such a toy out of curiosity
47 explosions of sich mines have already
been recorded in the
dunes people's republic this
pedal mine is living proof of the
sadistic savage nature of the ukrainian
regime and a symbol of its true attitude
towards the people of the east and
southeast of the country
and of course the people see and
understand this hence the treatment of
russian soldiers as liberators which is
widespread in the liberated territories
this in no way fits into the narrative
promoted by cuba
and its western sponsors
ukraine is therefore resorting to terror
and intimidation tactics in the her sons
of persian heart of regions
but
this cannot change the minds of people
who have seen the true face of the kiev
regime kiev is losing the battle for
mines and its western backers who are
waging a proxy war against russia to the
last ukrainian
are getting mired deeper and deeper in
supporting this anti-popular anti-human
regime
turning a blind eye to manifestations of
neo-nazism extreme nationalism
erusophobia they are also shooting
themselves in the foot with futile
attempts to isolate russia politically
and economically
then again that is something you will
have to answer for
to your own voters and taxpayers
as you will have to answer to the
international community for the
unprecedented mandations campaign to
discredit russia that you have unleashed
never
before since nazi doubles propaganda has
russia
has the world encountered such a degree
of falsification which western and
ukrainian psyops experts are using there
is no doubt that
history will be able to give the correct
assessment to all this our albanian
colleague
propounded today
about russian prisoners that are
allegedly being recruited by the russian
authorities however he forgot to mention
those released from ukrainian prisons
ukrainian prisoners
who were handed out weapons in the very
first days of the special military
operation and who
became
made themselves known by pillaging and
murders and continued to terrorize
ukrainian towns we will go into this
in detail at one of the future meetings
of the council
mr president
the so-called black sea initiative of
the un secretary general is considered
to be a sort of success story especially
in terms of the unhindered expert of
food from ukraine
however there are alarming trends here
as well
over the four weeks of export operations
only one of the 34 dry cargo ships went
to africa
this is completely inconsistent with the
originally stated goal of combating
hunger in countries in dire need of
grain
here of course it is also worth
recalling the public image failure with
the sending of the first vessel rosoni
which
essentially instead of bringing
long-awaited wheats to lebanon brought
corn instead in corn for animal feed
in this context there is much to think
about
regarding the comment made by the
secretary general in the port of odessa
on august 19th when he said that grain
exports and reduced prices on global
markets will not bring relief to needy
countries who cannot afford to buy them
anyway
this situation clearly reveals the true
causes of global food security issues
ukrainian green has nothing to do with
it the main reason is western countries
own economic miscalculations and the
consequences of anti-russian sanctions
which we've repeatedly spoken about in
this chamber
it was the sanctions that ruptured
logistical and financial chains
which in turn provoked a sharp job in
market supplies
supply excuses about the supposedly
target nature of unilateral measures
cannot fill hungry people's stomachs
we're calling all those involved
the package nature of the black sea
initiative with full seriousness and not
to postpone resolving the financial and
logistical problems that impede the
export of russian food and fertilizers
to the global market
we emphasize that the extension of the
green deal the term of which is 120 days
from the date of signing would be
facilitated by tangible results for
russian foreign trade operators
equivalent to those we are seeing for
ukrainian exports
so far there are still significant
reserves in this part of the grain deal
mr president it is no secret that the
western colleagues who requested today's
meeting were resolved to have it
coincide with
the independence day of ukraine much has
been said about this today
a number of our colleagues directly
point to russia as a threat to ukrainian
independence
we cannot agree with this
eight years after the launch of the
maidan project it has become obvious
that the main and in fact the only
threat to the independence of ukraine is
the current government in kiev
over these years
robust
mechanisms have been formed for the
external governance of ukraine which are
visible to the naked eye we know that at
all levels of government in all the key
agency of this country agencies of this
country there are western advisors
without whose concurrence not a single
major decision is made it is enough to
recall how in 2014 the notorious
victoria nuland
resolved issues regarding the formation
of the ukrainian government by phone
with the american ambassador in kiev or
recall the current president of the
united states joe biden boasting that he
had used crude blackmail to remove the
prosecutor general of ukraine
if this is independence then what is
dependence yes
and
is there anything for ukrainians to
celebrate on this day
throughout zilinski's reign and
particularly since february 24th
the opposition has been completely
eliminated in the country dissent has
been suppressed opposition media have
been shut down people are being
persecuted arrested
and put in prison just for reading
russian language news and watching
russian channels
and now in accordance with the new law
and collaborationism they are also
being imprisoned for accepting
humanitarian assistance for ukraine from
russia
ukraine has become fully transformed
into a backwards ruthless anti-russia
and is confidently moving towards a
complete ideological and political
bankruptcy
in order to assess the degree of this
profound russophobic degradation i would
like to once again quote the word said
the other day by ukrainian ambassador to
kazakhstan
petrovlevsky after the murder of daria
duguna he openly declared and i quote we
are trying to kill as many of them as
possible
the more russians we kill now the fewer
our children will have to kill that's
all end of quote
and this was said by the ambassador of a
country in which these same russians not
only live but make up a very significant
part of the population
does such a country and such an inhumane
regime have a future
our western colleagues can prolong its
agony but they cannot prevent its fiasco
therefore in conclusion i would like to
express my wish for the
brotherly people of ukraine to finally
gain freedom and the opportunity to
build a society that would respect
fundamental human rights and national
identity
and would live in peace with its
neighbors
that our is already close despite all
the efforts of the kiev regime and its
western patrons thank you
[Music]
i thank the
representative of the russian
federation for their statement i'll give
the floor to the representative of
mexico
thank you very much mr president
mr president my delegation
and with profound respect to the
statement delivered by president
silanski of ukraine
independence we are celebrating today
tomorrow and forever
we've also followed very closely and
with a great deal of attention the
recent visits by the secretary general
to ukraine and tokyo
we recognize his leadership
and his efforts which have led to
important agreements
in particular
to mitigate the impact of the food
crisis and to give us back hope
in this regard
we welcome the fact that the black sea
grain initiative
continues to operate on a regular basis
and it is made possible the delivery of
seven hundred and twenty thousand metric
tons of grain
to
markets throughout the world
as well as
the world food program supplies
all of this appears
ultimately and finally to be having an
important stabilizing impact
mexico believes that progress within the
framework of this black sea grain
initiative
is a major diplomatic
milestone
in
very difficult times
in this regard i'd also like to
recognize the extremely important work
of the president of turkey in
facilitating this agreement once again
we urge all parties in particular those
with the capacity to influence
to spare no efforts in order to keep the
channels of communication open
so as to establish dialogue
and put an end to hostilities
this progress it is clear that the
multilateral system in particular the
security council have not been able to
put an end to this war the invasion
the invasion of a sovereign country
ukraine by russia
is a flagrant violation
of
article 2.4 of the u.n charter
territorial acquisition
resulting from the illegal use of force
and foreign
must put an end to the war
and with that an end to the many
violations of international law in
particular international humanitarian
law
six months of bombings on hospitals
schools
residential areas
on basic civilian infrastructure
including
the supporia nuclear power plant and the
destruction
of cultural heritage
six months
of violations
of the immediate methods and means
of
warfare
of
violations of human rights
including
sexual and gender-based violence
and the indiscriminate use of weapons
the use of indiscriminate weapons such
as clusters and mines
[Music]
most emphatically call for an end to
these attacks
in particular those directed
against the civilian population
and indiscriminate attacks
and we also call upon the parties to
comply
with the principles of distinction
proportionality
and precautionary measures in conducting
hostilities
we express our greatest support for
the inquiries being carried out
by
the prosecutor of the icc as well as
the fact-finding mission
to
determine the facts with regard to the
alleged war crimes which have taken
place in online
accountability is a fundamental pillar
of our multilateral system
and those responsible for these crimes
that have been committed and which are
being committed in ukraine
must be brought to justice
mr president
mexico reiterates our deep concern at
the threat
posed by illicit flows
of weapons and trafficking of weapons in
the region
we must maintain
monitoring over the full life cycle of
weapons from their transfer
through brokering
and concluding
the
end users of those weapons
we must focus our action to ensure that
weapons do not fall in the hands of
those who should never have them
particularly
when
hostilities are over
the work of mexico and this council
will continue to focus
on
working towards and solidifying peace in
ukraine along these lines i'd like to
reiterate our urgent appeal
to negotiate a cessation of hostilities
and to seek a solution
through dialogue and diplomacy
i would conclude by reaffirming our
support for the independent sovereignty
and territorial integrity of ukraine
within
internationally recognized borders
these principles are enshrined in the
u.n charter
and all of us here
have committed to respecting and
upholding these principles thank you
i thank the representative of mexico for
their statement
i shall make now make a statement in my
capacity as a representative of china
colleagues
china's position on the ukraine issue is
consistent and clear
we always maintain
that the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of all countries should should
be respected
the purposes and principles of the u.n
charter upheld the legitimate security
concerns of all countries taken
seriously
and all efforts conducive to the
peaceful settlement of the crisis
supported
however the ukraine crisis is still
ongoing the fighting is still expanding
with growing spillover effects the
prospect of peace has yet to materialize
the international community eagerly
awaits the early resumption of peace
they also expect the security council to
place due road toward this end
what we need to reflect on is has the
council found the right direction
towards solving the issue
has the council
made earnest efforts to ease the
situation china is ready to work with
all peace-loving countries
to promote peace and dialogue and
facilitate the easing of the situation
at present the priority in our opinion
should be the following points
first there's a need to set up a safety
valve for the conflict the international
humanitarian
law should guide the conduct of parties
to the conflict
civilians and civilian facilities cannot
be
the target of military strikes
recently frequent attacks on the
parisian nuclear power plant have led to
extensive attention and concerns
casting
a nuclear shadow over the world
china calls on once again all relevant
parties to exercise restraint act with
caution
refrain from any action that may
compromise the safety and security of
the nuclear facility and avoid crossing
the nuclear safety red line
we also expect the iaea to conduct a
site visit to the double russia nuclear
power plant as soon as possible to make
a professional technical assessment of
the situation so as to take follow-up
measures to prevent a nuclear disaster
second
there is a need to reduce the
humanitarian tax as much as possible the
international community should on the
one hand make efforts to help ukrainian
refugees and displaced persons tied over
the difficulties and on the other hand
reduce the impacts of the conflict on
the global food energy and financial
stability
china commands secretary general
guterres and relevant parties for their
efforts to facilitate the
grain export agreement
we are pleased to see that over 20 ships
carrying over 700
000 tons of food have left ukraine for
multiple destinations around the world
this goes a long way towards
curbing rising food prices stabilize the
international food market and easing the
food shortages in developing countries
at the same time removing barriers to
the export of food and fertilizers from
russia is also highly important
we hope that the un can in accordance
with its mou with russia help address
the
chilling effect caused by relevant
countries and ensure the stable
and smooth running of the global
industrial chain and supply chain
these are challenging times for
developing countries cutting oda will
only make things worse
developed countries should face up to
the humanitarian impacts of such cuts
and adopt responsible policies and
measures
third
there is a need to leave an exit ramp
for diplomatic solutions peace can never
be achieved by imposing
sanctions
and pressure or sending weapons peace
must be
thoughtful
and maintained by all parties working
together no matter how complex the
situation is
how serious the differences are
the door to diplomacy and dialogue
cannot be closed
the positive progress on the issue of
grain export
shows us the potential of diplomacy and
the possibility of a political solution
we hope that russia and ukraine
continue the dialogue communication
between them so as to return
to diplomatic negotiations at an early
date and create
momentum and conditions needed for a
ceasefire the u.s and nato should
seriously reflect on the roles they have
been playing and focus their efforts on
what truly is conducive to peace
instead of pouring oil over fire
colleagues
the ukraine crisis and a series of
recent tense developments around the
world show that
in this era that urgently needs
solidarity and cooperation to
collectively address challenges we must
be highly vigilant against any
deliberate attempts to provoke troubles
and intensify division confrontation and
we must safeguard the global strategic
stability we should never allow the
world to slide into a new cold war
facts have proven that the cold war
mentality block confrontation must be
firmly rejected
in over 30 years after the end of the
cold war nato keeps expanding eastward
which doesn't make europe safer but has
sold the seed of conflict
we humanity are living in an indivisible
secure security community
and common security is in the utmost
common interest of all countries
security of a country should not come at
the expense of that of another country
and security of a region cannot be
realized by beefing up military blocks
today in the 21st century the cold war
mentality and zero-sum game are long
outdated concepts
obsessing over military force
and seeking absolute security will only
lead to
constant escalation
of the original situation which is not
in the interest of any party
facts have proven that
decoupling and choosing sites
must be firmly rejected
the economies around the world are
deeply integrated certain countries
wantonly impose unilateral sanctions
exercise long-arm jurisdiction
criticize and weaponize economic trade
and technology
insist on decoupling and building small
yard high fans
which have led to further difficulties
in people's livelihood in developing
countries and threaten the global food
energy and finance security
developing countries should not be made
to bear the brunt of geopolitical
conflicts and major country rivalry they
have the right to independently decide
their foreign policies and
should not be forced to choose sides
facts have proven that
double standard and selective
application must be firmly rejected
upholding the purposes and principles of
the u.n charter and respecting
sovereignty and territorial integrity
should not
be just quoted
all countries should actually abide by
these principles in practice and should
have consistency on different issues
involving different countries
while matching their words with deeds
with regard to state sovereignty and
territorial integrity the chinese people
have deep understanding of and strong
feelings about it through first-hand
experience china consistently respects
the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of other countries and is
determined to firmly safeguard its own
sovereignty and territorial integrity
the ukraine crisis is a major test of
our generation's ability to maintain
peace
standing at this historical crossroads
what do you want to have peaceful
turmoil cooperation
or confrontation
progress or regression
we must make the right choice a choice
worthy of the people's trust
and of our times
i resume my function as president of the
council
i now give the floor
to his excellency
interim of the delegation of european
union to the united nations
thank you president i have the honor to
speak on behalf of the european union
and its 27 member states
the candidate countries north macedonia
montenegro albania and the republic of
moldova
the country of the stabilization and
association process and potential
candidate bosnia ziggovina
georgia andorra and san marino aligned
themselves with this statement
president we welcome today's discussion
on ukraine it is essential that the
security council remains ceased of
russia's war of aggression against
ukraine
i thank the secretary general and under
secretary general dicarlo for their
briefings and welcomed the intervention
by president zielinski at this meeting
first of all let me congratulate ukraine
on the 31st anniversary of its
independence
the fact that today also marks the sixth
month since russia's unprovoked and
illegal aggression provides a stark
reminder that independence can never be
taken for granted
do you recognize the tremendous courage
displayed by ukraine and its people in
defense of its independence
as the under secretary general told us
the office of the high commissioner for
human rights has verified over 13 000
civilian casualties since russia's
attack
with the true numbers being considerably
higher
we express our deepest sympathy to the
families of the victims and reaffirm our
commitment to continue our support to
ukraine in any way we can
do you reiterate its strongest
condemnation for the continued violation
by russia of the u.n charter as well as
disregard of the united nations general
assembly resolutions adopted in march
this year by an overwhelming majority of
un members
we also deplore russia's failure to
comply with the legally binding order of
the international court of justice to
immediately seize its use of force
against ukraine
and we call upon the russian federation
to comply with its obligation under
international law
including the u.n charter international
humanitarian law and human rights law
the perpetrators of war crimes and of
other serious violations
as well as the responsible government
officials and military representatives
will be held accountable
the u actively supports all measures to
ensure accountability for human rights
violations and violations of
international humanitarian law
committed during the russian aggression
in ukraine
president the past months we have seen
an emerging risk of nuclear calamity in
europe
it is deplorable that we even need to
say that a nuclear power plant should
never be used as a military base
the deployment of russian military
personnel and weaponry at the nuclear
facility is unacceptable and disregards
the safety security and
safeguard principles that all iaea
members have committed to respect
we urge the russian federation to
immediately withdraw its military forces
and all other unauthorized personnel
from the zapposia nuclear power plant
and its immediate surroundings so that
the operator and ukrainian authorities
can resume their sovereign
responsibilities within ukraine's
international recognized borders and so
that the legitimate operating staff can
conduct their duties without outside
interference threats or unacceptably
harsh working conditions
an iaea mission urgently needs to enter
the power plant to address nuclear
safety security and safeguard concerns
in a manner that respects full ukrainian
sovereignty and its control of its its
territory and infrastructure
staff must be able to access all nuclear
facilities in ukraine safely and without
impediment and engage directly and
without interference with ukrainian
personnel responsible for the operation
of these facilities
the global implications of russia's
aggression are well documented mr
president we support the un's global
crisis response group launched in the
aftermath of russia's invasion with a
view to addressing rocketing food and
energy prices
we welcome the progress made in
implementing the black sea grain
initiative and reiterate our gratitude
to the secretary general and turkey for
facilitating its agreement
and acknowledge the positive role played
by other actors such as the african
union leadership in coming to an
arrangement
we call for continued strict
implementation of the black sea grain
initiative with a view to addressing
rising food prices globally
with our solidarity lanes initiative
aimed at boosting exports from ukraine
over land due is proud to have
contributed to increasing ukrainian
exports of cereals oil seeds and related
products from 1.3 million tons in april
to 2.8 million tons in july
we're also supporting agricultural
production and resilience in the most
affected countries
view welcome welcomes the active
involvement of the secretary general
his recent visit to ukraine and istanbul
demonstrate his dedication to address
this crisis and the uk will continue to
support his efforts and those of his
staff including the joint coordination
center
we welcome the secretary general's
schools to demilitarize the zabarizian
nuclear power plant as well as the
establishment of a fact-finding mission
to investigate the incident in a
detention facility in oleni or vivka
president in conclusion the un's member
states reaffirmed their commitment to
the sovereignty independence and
territorial integrity of ukraine within
within its international recognized
borders and extending to its territorial
sea
president this war is senseless the
humanitarian consequence for millions of
civilians are disastrous russia could
end it tomorrow if it wanted
until that happens human lives are
wasted and the world's global fallout
continues at a time in history where we
should focus on the planetary crisis
which are impacting us all
this is why we reiterate our demand for
the immediate cessation of the military
aggression against ukraine by the
russian federation
as well as for the full immediate and
unconditional withdrawal of its forces
and military equipment from ukraine's
territory
in the meantime we wish to assure our
partners around the world that eu will
continue to demonstrate its global
solidarity to address the impacts of
russians aggression
especially on the most vulnerable i
thank you
i thank his excellency
the representative from the eu for his
statement
there are no other names inscribed on
the list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned